let me ask about
ein rand okay so it just so happens that
i've gotten
she's entered
a few conversations in this podcast and
just looking at academic philosophy or
just philosophers in general they seem
to ignore ayn rand
do you have a sense of why that is does
she ever come into play
her ideas of
objectivism
come into play of discussions of um
a good life
uh from the perspective of uh
existentialism
in how you teach it and how you think
about it is she
somebody who you find it all interesting
so no i don't think she is
[Laughter]
but it's been a long time since i've
read her stuff i read it in high school
i read the fountainhead in high school
and atlas shrugged but that's at this
point a very long time ago i think i
read something about objective
epistemology or something too
so you know my my view about her could
be based on a total misunderstanding of
of what she's up to
but sort of my my caricature of her and
tell me if i've got it wrong is that
she's
sort of
motivated by
a kind of i think it's maybe sometimes
you call it libertarianism but
maybe let's in the context of our
discussion um tie it back to sartre a
kind of view according to which we're
the being who has to contend with the
fact that we're radically free to do
stuff and we're just not being
courageous or brave enough when we don't
do that and the people to admire
are the people who make stuff out of
nothing
um so maybe that's a bad caricature no
no but i i think uh no i think that's
pretty accurate i'm not again very
knowledgeable about the full
depth of her philosophy but i think she
takes
a view of the world that's similar to
sartre in
in the conclusions
but
makes stronger statements about
epistemology
that first of all everything is knowable
and there's some you should always
operate through reason
like reason is very important like uh
it's like uh
you start with a few axioms and you
build on top of that and
the axioms that everybody should operate
on are the same
again reality is objective it's not
subjective
so from that you can derive
the entirety of how humans should behave
at the individual level
and at the societal level and there's a
few conclusions
she would talk about virtue of
selfishness
and sort of a lot of people use that to
dismiss her look she's very selfish and
so on she
actually meant something very different
is like it's it's more like a the sartre
thing take responsibility for yourself
understand
what uh forces you're operating under
and make the best of this life and
that's how you can be the best member of
societies by making the best
life you can and just focus on yourself
like fix your own problems first yeah
and then
and that will make you the best member
of society of your family of loved ones
of
friends and so on i think the reason
she's disliked
obviously on the philosophy side she's
disliked because a little bit like
nietzsche she's like she's literary
uh i think and the reason she's publicly
disliked
uh in sort of public conversations is
because of how sure she is of herself so
that which is some of the philosophers
have been known to do like make very
strong statements like hell is other
people but she was making very strong
statements about basically everything
and
but it is the reason i bring her up is
you know she is an influential
thinker
that is not for some reason often
brought up as such it's not acknowledged
how influential she is
you know i was recently looking at like
a list of
the most
important women of the 20th century in
terms of thought not science or but like
thought
and she wasn't in that list
and i just i see this time and time
again and it doesn't make sense to me
why she's so
kind of dismissed because clearly she's
an author of some of the most read books
like ever
and she clearly had very strong ideas
that should be contended with you know
um
and that that's why it kind of didn't
make sense to me
because she's a also a creature of her
time and an important one
she's a creation of the soviet union
somebody who left because of that and so
some of her the strength of her ideas
has to do
with how much she dislikes that
particular uh
philosophy and uh way of life
but also she's a creature of like sartre
and like death whole like nietzsche
and so on now one of the other
criticisms is she doesn't integrate
herself into this history she keeps
basically kind of implying that she's
purely original in all her thoughts even
though she's kind of citing a lot a lot
of other people but again many
philosophers do this kind of thing as if
as if they've uh they are truly original
and they're not it is interesting and
also what's interesting about her is she
is a woman she is a strong feminist
and
it feels like with simone de beauvoir
you know like she seems like she's a
very
person in this moment of history that
shouldn't be fully forgotten
interesting yeah well so i i mean i
don't have a lot to add i i will just
say
um
this i mean the way
she and bevoir seem to me from your
description of her and remembering what
i remember from 35 years ago
they seem
pretty opposite from one another
like one of the things i find
interesting about beauvoir is that
she takes seriously
the thing that sartre didn't which is
our throneness which is our um the sense
in which
we're born into a situation that's
already got a significance for her
i think it was easier for her to to
recognize that than sartre because she
was a woman
and sartre seems to act as if
you know there are no constraints or at
least there shouldn't be
we're pretty close
as you know privileged white males yeah
exactly if we could just get rid of the
last bits of them we would be god like
we're supposed to be yeah uh and i think
beauvoir sort of sees things differently
i think she reckon one does not one's
not born but becomes a woman she says so
how does that happen well you're thrown
into your culture and your culture
starts treating you in a certain way
because of your gender and that starts
to form your understanding and your
experience of things and by the time
you're grown up well you're you're
pretty well formed by that
that seems a fact
it's a fact about sartre too though it
was harder for him to notice it because
uh he was formed into the into his
privilege
but the world reminds us of our
throneness
for some more than others yes absolutely
and and for people who have to contend
on a daily basis with the fact that
the
social position they're thrown into is
one that um negates them or one that
oppresses them or one that sort of
pushes them to the side in some way or
another i mean the black experience is
is interesting in this respect too
franz fanon who's a contemporary of
sarton both wars
writes about it and it's very familiar
the things that he's saying now but you
know he he writes back in the 50s about
being a black man in paris and getting
on getting on an elevator with a woman
alone and how like you know
her reaction to him not knowing him not
having any views about any reason to
have any views about him sort of puts
him in a particular social position with
respect to her
and
that that's um if you if you don't have
that experience it's much harder to
recognize
the um the way in which what we're
thrown into is something we might not
have chosen
so the idea that that
that that's not an aspect of our
existence um which as you describe ayn
rand's views it's she sounds more like
sorry she sounds more like it
either it's not an aspect of our
existence or at least we ought to sort
of aim at its not being yeah almost act
as if it's not yeah exactly if it's not
and so i i think from my point of view i
don't i don't pretend that i'm
explaining the public reception of her
i'm just sort of trying to try to say
how i understand her in this
um intellectual context from my point of
view that's not something big big to
miss and the ambition to think that
really what's happening is that we're
all the same we're all rational beings
we're all beings who if we just got the
axioms of our existence right and made
good judgments and reasoned in an
appropriate way
would um
optimize ourselves
that feels to me like
a kind of natural
end point of
the philosophical tradition i mean plato
starts off with a view that helps us in
that direction and the enlightenment
moves us further in that direction
but from my point of view that movement
has led us astray
because it's missed something really
important that's crucial to the kind of
being that that we are
yeah it misses
the music exactly
you